[MUSIC PLAYING]
DRISHTI GUPTA: Hello, and
welcome to Google Cloud.
I'm Drishti, and I
have Michael with me.
We are solution
engineers for Google.
Today, we will show
you a demo that
depicts one way to modernize
your legacy Java applications
using Anthos on Google Cloud.
Java is the most
common run time when
it comes to deploying
applications
in production environments.
Consequently, it
comes as no surprise
that most companies are
intent on protecting
their past strategic
investments in Java, including
retaining internal Java
developer expertise.
There are hundreds and thousands
of existing enterprise Java
applications.
Most of them are actively
maintained, but have not
been actively developed.
Patching and maintenance
of the application
and its infrastructure
continues to grow.
The only way left to
modernize these applications
is to rewrite them, which is
tremendously time-consuming.
At Google Cloud,
we have identified
few different solutions to
address the pain points,
and today we will be showing
a demo of option number one--
modernize with containerization.
When you onboard Java
application to container
with Anthos, an
automated development
process with a
software pipeline,
you'll see a 37% TCO
savings instantly.
Furthermore, automating
testing and refactoring
the application, one starts
to see an additional 78%
in TCO savings.
First, let me provide
you with a few anecdotes
so that the demo
resonates better with you.
Hipster Shop is a company who
has a modern online boutique
website running on Google Cloud.
They also maintain an
on-premise VMware environment
that is primarily hosting legacy
applications, most of which
are no longer
getting new features
and are simply
keep-the-lights on apps.
One such application
is the legacy CRM Java
app, which they would
like to modernize and run
on Google Cloud.
Hipster Shop's Google
Cloud environment--
they have Anthos clusters
running on Google Kubernetes
engine to host their
modern applications.
They utilize Anthos
configuration management
to keep common Kubernetes
configuration and policies
in sync and up to date
across the clusters.
The source of truth for these
config files and policies
must reside in a Git repo.
So Hipster Shop leverages
their own instance
of GitLab running on GKE.
They also use Anthos Service
Mesh on their production
clusters to collect mesh
telemetry, define service level
objectives, and
secure communications
across the microservices that
make up their applications.
In their on-prem
VMware environment,
Hipster Shop uses
vCenter Server Appliance
installed on an ESXi host
to manage their inventory
of virtual machines.
To begin modernizing
the apps running on VMs,
Hipster Shop's operators needed
to set up Migrate for Anthos
to snapshot their VMs and
generate their container
images.
The legacy CRM
Java application is
deployed on a WebLogic
application server.
They also installed the WebLogic
server Kubernetes operator
on that Anthos cluster to
automate the deployment
and management of a
WebLogic environment running
on Kubernetes.
Let me now show you
these components running
live in VMware and
Google Cloud platform.
Hipster Shop's
VMware ESXi host is
running on an on-premise
bare metal machine.
They manage and configure
their VM inventory
through the vCenter
Server Appliance.
The legacy CRM Java application
that Hipster Shop's operators
will modernize is running on
Red Hat Enterprise Linux VM
that you see here.
WebLogic server is installed
on the virtual machine
and provides the WebLogic
application server
that the legacy CRM
application runs on.
Here's the front end of the
Hipster Shop's legacy CRM Java
application.
The application follows standard
Java Enterprise Edition design
principles.
For example, the domain
and the facade layers
of the application utilize
Java Spring Framework
and the Java messaging service.
And the presentation layers
use JavaServer Pages and Faces.
Let me now show you
Hipster Shop's modern cloud
infrastructure running
on Google Cloud platform.
Hipster Shop's modern
online boutique
is running on two Anthos
Kubernetes clusters,
staging for testing
and production.
These clusters will also host
the legacy CRM application
after the migration from VMware.
Both of these clusters run
on Google Kubernetes engine.
But with Anthos,
Hipster Shop can
have clusters running across
multiple cloud and on-prem
environments, such
as AWS or VMware,
and they will be
viewed and managed
from the Google Cloud console.
There is also a separate Migrate
for Anthos processing cluster
that will run the migration
of the Java application VMware
without having to worry about
production applications being
affected.
Finally, you will see
Hipster Shop's GitLab cluster
running on GKE to host their
Anthos configuration management
repo.
I will now pass
it off to Michael,
who will play the role of
a Hipster Shop's operator
and will modernize the legacy
CRM Java application using
Google Cloud's Anthos solution.
MICHAEL INTINDOLA:
Thanks, Drishti.
I will first use
Migrate for Anthos
to containerize the Hipster
Shop legacy CRM application
so that it can be deployed
to the Anthos clusters
running on Google
Kubernetes Engine.
Migrate for Anthos uses the
[? MQCTL ?] command line
interface to define the
source and the destination
of the migration and to kick
off the migration process.
As you can see
here, I've already
set up the VMware environment
as the source of the migration.
To begin the migration of
the legacy CRM application,
I first create a migration plan
using the [? MQCTL ?] command
line interface.
The migration plan will provide
details such as the VMware
virtual machine that hosts
the source application,
and where the new containerized
images from the migration
will be stored.
Migrate for Anthos
is able to determine
what files from
the virtual machine
are needed to produce
a containerized image
of the source application.
I only need it to specify the
directories that should not
be included in the migration
and the directories that
contain data that
should be persisted
to a persistent volume.
When I finish running
this migration plan
on the Migrate for Anthos
processing cluster,
a set of artifacts are
automatically generated for me
and stored in a Google
Cloud Storage bucket.
I can download these
artifacts to my Cloud
Shell or local machine.
These artifacts
include a Docker file
to update my source
application's container
image, a persistent volume on
a Google Cloud persistent disk
that contains my source
application's data,
and a Kubernetes
manifest that I will
use to deploy my application
to a Kubernetes cluster.
In the Docker file
artifact, I can
see that the Migrate
for Anthos runtime
is used as the base
image, and it's
combined with a
non-runnable base
image that contains a replica
of the source virtual machine.
I can also make updates to
packages in the container
and can upgrade the
Migrate for Anthos runtime
in the future for new
releases or bug fixes.
I can make changes
to this Docker file
as I would to any
other Docker file.
I make the changes,
rebuild the image,
and push to a
container registry,
such as Google Cloud's
private Container Registry.
In the Kubernetes
manifest file that
was generated from
my application,
I have a stateful set, with
Hipster Shop's Legacy CRM
container image specified
in the image field.
The WebLogic Admin Console and
the Hipster Shop legacy CRM
are exposed on port 7,001.
So I also expose that port
on the source application's
container.
A load balancer service is also
defined so that the application
is accessible from a browser.
Finally, there is
a persistent volume
that specifies the Google
Cloud persistent disk, which
contains the Legacy CRM migrated
data and a persistent volume
claim that mounts that volume
to the Kubernetes container.
To deploy the Hipster Shop
legacy CRM application,
I apply the Kubernetes manifest
file to my staging Anthos
cluster, where I will be able
to test the application's
functionality before releasing
the application in production.
Once the deployment
is complete, I
can navigate to my
Kubernetes services
to find the end point for
my Hipster Shop legacy CRM
application.
It seems like there is something
preventing the application
from loading.
Luckily, I know exactly
what the issue is.
By default, all new applications
on the staging and production
clusters have a
Kubernetes network policy
that prevents external traffic
from reaching the container.
This network policy is defined
in the Kubernetes configuration
file that is stored in
Hipster Shop's Anthos Config
Management repository.
As Drishti explained
earlier, Hipster Shop
is using their own
instance of GitLab
running on GKE to host their
Anthos Config Management
repository.
This repository contains
Kubernetes configuration
and policy files that
are automatically
applied to Hipster Shop's
staging and production
clusters.
And the configurations
and policies
are kept in sync with this
source of truth repository
to prevent any unwarranted
deletions or changes.
The Anthos config
management repository
is structured in
a way that allows
me to apply configuration
and policies
across all clusters at an
individual cluster level
or at a namespace level.
If I go to the directory for
the namespace that contains
the hipster legacy
CRM application,
I can open the
network-policy.yaml,
and I'll see the policy that
is currently preventing me from
accessing the Hipster
Legacy CRM application.
I will make a change to
this configuration file
to allow all external traffic
to reach my application.
And I will commit my
change to the repository.
I can now go check if my
configuration took effect
by refreshing.
Great.
I can now access the
Hipster Shop legacy CRM.
Only this time, it's running on
an Anthos Kubernetes cluster.
The network policy change that
I made in the Anthos Config
Management repository
was almost immediately
synced across my staging
and production clusters.
After testing the Hipster Legacy
CRM in the staging environment,
I can promote the
application to production
to begin taking advantage
of the rich feature
set of Anthos Service Mesh.
Anthos Service Mesh
provides traffic management,
observability, and
secure communication
across all the services
running on my Anthos clusters.
From this single
pane of glass, I
am able to view the
10 micro services that
make up Hipster Shop's modern
online boutique website.
But I'm also able to
see the Legacy CRM that
was just migrated from VMware.
Anthos Service
Mesh automatically
proxies all requests
between services
and collects a
standard set of metrics
without having to make any
changes to the application
source code.
I see those metrics
displayed in this table,
and I will see them across many
of the other Anthos Service
Mesh screens, as these metrics
help gauge the performance
of my application services.
Another helpful view
in Anthos Service Mesh
is the topology view, which,
again, shows the same services
that are running on Hipster
Shop's Anthos clusters,
but in a graphical
format that highlights
the inbound and outbound
connections of each service.
And I can see here
the Hipster Legacy CRM
service that I just deployed.
If I click on the
service, I will
see this set of standard
performance metrics displayed
in the widget on the right.
Now as an operator,
my job requires
that I keep all of
Hipster Shop's services
running across the staging
and production clusters
at an optimal state.
You might ask, what
is an optimal state?
And the answer is that
it really depends.
Each service is different.
There may be some services
where slight degradation
in performance will negatively
impact the end user's
experience, while other
services may not be as delicate
and slight performance
changes will go unnoticed.
With Anthos Service
Mesh, I have the ability
to set Service-Level Objectives,
or SLOs, for each service
so that I can proactively
monitor Hipster Shop's
applications' health and
ensure that end users are not
having a negative experience.
I've already set up an SLO
Hipster Shop's legacy CRM
application.
Let's take a closer look at
how I defined this objective.
The metric I'm interested in
monitoring and maintaining
for this service is latency, or
how long it takes the Hipster
Shop Legacy CRM
service to respond
when it receives a request.
Next, I specify my
latency threshold.
That is the maximum
amount of latency
I'm willing to accept for
my service to be considered
at an optimal state.
I set the threshold
to be 20 milliseconds.
I then set the
time period I want
to use for evaluating the SLO
to be a rolling one-day period.
Finally, I choose
a performance goal.
With my goal set to 90%, I am
saying that the Hipster Shop
Legacy CRM service
latency should
be below the threshold of 20
milliseconds 90% of the day.
So that wraps up our Java
application modernization demo
with Anthos.
In this demo, you saw how
a Java Spring application
was migrated off of a virtual
machine running on VMware
to an Anthos Kubernetes cluster
running on Google Cloud's
Kubernetes Engine.
You saw how a Kubernetes network
policy or any other company
good reason or
policy file can be
synced across multiple
clusters in a matter of seconds
using Anthos Config Management.
And finally, you saw how an
operator can use Anthos Service
Mesh and the
observability metrics
it provides to set
service-level objectives
on their containerized services.
Thank you, and we look
forward to showing you
more application
modernization tools
on Google Cloud in the future.
[MUSIC PLAYING]